müsste nachmachen natürlich natürlich
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es ein tolles türkisches
Rezept könnt ihr auch sehr gut jetzt zum
Ramadan zubereiten und zwar Malik Köfte
ein köfte-rezept das viele sehr mögen
vor allem ist es in köfte-rezept was
sehr günstig ist denn es wird ein
bisschen geschummelt was den
Fleischanteil angeht Köfte sind der
Hackbällchen die eigentlich immer pur
aus Hackfleisch bestehen und eben noch
bisschen Gemüse dazu aber um das Gericht
bisschen günstiger zu machen und weniger
fleischlastik werden wir jetzt ein
bisschen Grieß und Bulgur mit
reinschmuggeln dann ist das Ganze
wirklich auch ein bisschen
erschwinglicher und man ist eben auch
generell einfach weniger Fleisch ich
zeige euch mal kurz die Zutaten ich
verwende dafür kochendes Wasser 150 g
feinen Bulgur ein Ei 200g Hackfleisch
das vom Rind 200 g Weichweizengrieß zwei
Esslöffel Mehl ich habe etwas Paprika
mag Salz und Pfeffer Minze Kreuzkümmel
und Zimt und jetzt mache ich so ich
nehme den bulldogan
ist jetzt hier ungefähr eine halbe Tasse
das sind große Gläser und die gleiche
Menge an Wasser kommt mit dazu
einfach kochendes Wasser und es geht bei
feinem Bulgur ganz gut man übergießt es
jetzt nämlich und lässt dann einfach nur
ziehen
das dauert jetzt einfach kurz zwei drei
Minuten
so sieht das ganze jetzt aus schön
eingezogen und jetzt gebt ihr einfach
alle Zutaten hier rein
und Hackfleisch
hier noch etwas Weichweizengrieß
Mehl
dicke Würze
und Paprika mal
und jetzt einfach alle Zutaten schön
verkneten
also ihr könnt auch wirklich wenn ihr
vegan oder vegetarisch seid das Fleisch
weglassen das tut dem Geschmack so ein
bisschen Abbruch aber es schmeckt
trotzdem sehr gut man kann ja dann
einfach ein bisschen mehr Würze
dazugeben bisschen mehr Paprika mag und
Tomatenmark und am Ende muss ich sagen
fällt wahrscheinlich gar nicht auf dass
da gar kein Fleisch drin ist
wenn das jetzt hier gut ist
dauert so ein bisschen
dann einfach kurz abdecken und
durchziehen lassen
jetzt nehme ich hier den Teller habe
auch schon mal Wasser aufgesetzt gleich
zum kochen denn es geht jetzt hier ganz
schnell mit einem mittleren
Eisportionierer könnt ihr jetzt hier die
Portionen abstechen
und dann entweder Kugeln formen oder
ebenso wie sich es jetzt hier für die
sommerliche Köfte gehört so lange Köfte
also lange Frikadellen
und die lege ich dann erstmal auf den
Teller
das ist ein bisschen kneten
und dann langsam und wenn es ein
bisschen klebt in der Hand einfach ein
bisschen Wasser nehmen
könnte die Hände leicht befeuchten
[Musik]
so jetzt ist hier alles vorbereitet und
ich habe jetzt hier Wasser da kommt ein
Esslöffel Salz rein
Spritzer Zitronensaft
[Musik]
und jetzt kommen die hier rein
und dann dürfen sie so lange garen ich
schalte den Herd auch ein bisschen
runter das nicht so sprudelnd kocht und
dann dürfen sie so lange garen bis sie
an der Oberfläche schwimmen und ich kann
gleich dann schon mal noch die Soße
zubereiten das nämlich eine Buttersoße
ich schwenkt ich schmelze auf dafür
einfach etwas Butter mit Tomatenmark
Paprika mag und dann kommen sie nach dem
Kochen dort rein
und das könnt ihr jetzt so perfekt
vorbereiten die könnt ihr auch im
Kühlschrank lassen bis ihr sie kochen
wollt und am Abend wenn ihr dann eben
Abendessen wollt oder eben fast ein
Brechen macht dann könnte es aus dem
Kühlschrank holen alles schon
vorbereitet Joghurt die Paprika Soße und
dann nur noch kurz kochen und fertig
[Musik]
Tomaten und paprika-markt schön
angebraten und ich muss sagen die köpfte
die wollen hier nicht an der Oberfläche
schwimmen aber sie sind echt schon durch
ich hatte jetzt so etwa sechs Minuten
drin jetzt nehmt ihr die aus dem Wasser
raus und dann kommen sie hier rein
[Musik]
dann ist jetzt hier mein Köfte Gericht
fertig ich habe jetzt hier noch etwas
Naturjoghurt sondern Sahnejoghurt 10%
natürlich mit etwas Knoblauch verfeinert
Salz und Pfeffer das passt nämlich
perfekt dazu und ich würde sagen Holger
du darfst jetzt probieren
hallo
oh mein Gott das ist Köfte aber nicht
was andere Art von Köfte nämlich mit
ganz wenig Hackfleisch perfekt ja
perfekt für Menschen die weniger Fleisch
essen wollen hier ein Joghurt dazu und
theoretisch wenn man Hackfleisch ganz
weg lässt kann man sogar vegan und
vegetarisch zubereiten Gericht
sieht schon lecker aus also war das
schon sieht
vorbereiten ich meine ich koche ja auch
gerade nebenher die zweite Portion
fertig
aber wenn ich jetzt eine große Anzahl an
Gästen oder gerade für uns als Familie
das zubereite geht es in dem größeren
Topf alles auf einmal und fertig und
dann Wasser aufgekocht ja die sind nicht
frittiert nicht gebacken zu Hause
riecht's nicht haarwasch Tag ist nicht
kaputt ja
also probieren mal yes
ich bin gespannt
hat wenn es kein Fleisch gibt und ich
sag immer es gibt halt jetzt weniger
ohne die Suppe
sind so frittierte bulgur-bällchen mit
Hackfleisch drinnen
super lecker
es ist Paprikamark oder Tomatenmark aber
man kann es auch wenn man es nicht als
lange vormacht auch zu kleinen
[Musik]
und auch gerne einfrieren und dann hat
man immer bei Bedarf kann man sich Köfte
rausholen aufkochen eine kleine Portion
ist vielleicht auch gut wenn man alleine
wohnt nicht so oft kochen will und sich
dann die Frikadellen eben schon
vorbereitet und einfriert und hat dann
immer portionsweise wie bei Gnocchi
Schupfnudeln einfach was was man schnell
in der Pfanne zubereiten kann
tatsächlich immer so ein Fach bei mir zu
Hause
frisch zusammen kam habe ich immer sowas
auf Vorrat vorbereitet und hatte dann so
ein fachmantel so ein Fach davon so
einfach hiervon ich hatte sogar Pizza
vorgebacken selber und dann konnte ich
das immer mal einfach zubereiten wenn
ich keine Zeit hatte Pizza auch
vorgepacken einfach nur so 10 Minuten
und dann den Rest wir sind fertig
also probiert es gerne aus schreibt mir
euer Feedback wir können auch gerne
weitere food prep Rezepte machen also wo
ich sagen kann wenn ihr sagt ihr wollt
weiterhin wissen was man gut auf Vorrat
vorbereiten kann und einfrieren kann
schreibt mir gerne ich denke mir dann
noch mehr Sachen aus ja mach's gut bis
zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]